I wouldn't have missed this I've been on
this is horrible what's happening to us
and uh whatever I have some ladies over
there I met they drove all the way in
from Oregon this was just a little sign
of show of respect for Texas and what
they're doing we just want people to
come into our country legally and
respect our way of life and the laws and
to welcome in I mean my grandparents
Came From Italy and so I mean you know
we're all immigrants of some sort but we
came in to be become American to love
americ political pundits certain
individuals certain certain groups
claiming to be an army of God are coming
to our community to spread hate and to
spread
dissension
and I just I'm troubled by that because
this is not who we are we need this to
stop and there's only one individual
that can stop this and that is our
governor but as you may have heard he's
going to be here on Sunday last time he
was here he brought four of his
buddies now he's bringing 10 more total
of 14 Governors coming to our community
to spread hate false narrative and to
put our culture down and to put our
community down now this Governor needs
to
represent 100% of the people that are
Texans you know on April the8th at
exactly
1257 this community is going to go dark
for four and a half minutes it's going
to be a total solar eclipse and I was
hoping when I heard about this seven
years ago that we that Eagle Pass would
be recognized as the first point where
you can see the eclipse but now we're
known at this point
where a
potential uh Civil War might
commence